[Music]
[Applause]
uh we've been talking about shohei
uttani here and what the future is
because uh he was betting on himself and
I looked like he was going to sign this
600 million or whatever it was now
probably needing surgery and what do you
do if you're the Angels or another team
interested in him how long is he going
to be a pitcher can you put incentives
in a contract for pitching numbers so I
thought why not have Jeff pass it on
he's the guy who have all the answers
their Baseball Insider at the mothership
and he joins us on the program Jeff
thanks for joining us walk me through
the last couple of days and where we are
right now with shohei uttani
it was a bummer
bummer like that that that's been the
general sentiment throughout the
baseball industry everyone's just sad
because
the best thing to come around this sport
in a really really long time
and I think he was
baseball's opportunity in a football
dominated world not to be Irrelevant
this winter like I I was starting to
treat we like I had a call with a couple
of our other reporters last week
um trying to map out what the off season
is going to look like and I was like I
want to have a new otami story every day
because that's what it feels like it was
going to Warrant you were going to get
this guy who was going to get the
largest contract in North American
Sports history I mean we were talking
down six upward of 700 million dollars
you do not see that anything close to
that in the NFL or the NBA or the NHL or
I mean even even Messi's contract uh
with MLS and so because of just the the
sheer size of that I thought this was
going to be the the news story that
could compete with the NFL and all of a
sudden it's just like you know poof it
goes away because you got a tiny little
ligament right there uh that just screws
things up again and again and again okay
does he have surgery on the horizon
having not seen the MRI and not knowing
the exact severity of the the sprain in
his elbow I can't say yes or no but
it was interesting to me that
perimenation the Angels general manager
came out and said that he's got a tear
in his UCL teams will speak in coded
language about elbows all the time they
will talk about a forearm strain they'll
talk about inflammation they'll talk
about all these other things that are
not like tear in the UCL so uh maybe
shohei Otani tries to go about it the
same way that he did last time which
remember back in June of 2018 uh had a
UCL tear tried to use platelet-rich
plasma and stem cells and ultimately
ended up getting surgery in October
um I think he's probably gonna hit for a
couple weeks let the inflammation go
down take another look at it and uh if
it looks like it needs surgery I would
imagine that that's what's on the
horizon okay but if we're looking is it
Tommy John surgery every looking at
something yeah it would be yeah it would
be yeah it would be Tommy Johnson
correct there's no there's there's
nothing there's nothing that you can do
to fix this outside of Tommy job okay
what's this do to the contract that he's
going to ask for in the off season
well I think 650 or 700 million or even
600 million are out of the realm of
possibility at this point uh and there
are a number of people inside the
industry Dan uh as well as my colleagues
Buster only being one of them who don't
think he's gonna necessarily get 500
million that's still the number for me
that that's still where when I take the
combination of
elite elite hitter best in the game this
season
uh true like genuine true star shohehe
is a star in baseball baseball doesn't
have a lot of those he is an
international commodity he is in many
ways the face of the game right now so
you have great hitter and star
that goes a long long way that gets you
to 400 plus right there
um and frankly Jacob degrom
signed for 185 million dollars this
winter
Jacob degrom's a guy who's been hurt for
the last few years and who had a Tommy
John surgery on his resume already and
who in the first year of his contract
needed Tom Angel down surgery and it
just speaks to the point Dan all it
takes in free agency is one team to
value a guy at a certain level and I
think the barrier of entry for shohei
Otani now has been lowered to the point
where you might see some teams that
would have thought that the 650 million
dollars is going to be too excessive who
think well if it's starting at 4 or 450
and it's going to get up to five 525
somewhere in that range maybe we should
be in there maybe we should be poking
around trying to find the guy who is the
most talented player we've ever seen at
a relative discount to what he could
have been had he gone completely healthy
to the winner but I'm also wondering
about this with Otani can you put in
incentives let's say I sign him for 400
million and I have 100 million dollars
in incentives for pitching can I do that
if he reaches certain number of starts
or winnings or era can so you can do
that contractually
oh a hundred percent you can do that and
what shohei Otani can do is uh give you
a big old middle finger I don't know why
it's your him do you bother with
incentives when you know that there's
going to be a team that guarantees you
everything could this help the Angels
could this help the angels this injury
yeah because I think there are probably
going to be some teams that are scared
and that want to by the way I I wasn't
meaning to dismiss your incentive like
it's a very no no you didn't give me the
middle finger you're saying that Otani
may give me the middle finger
no he's too polite for that I would be
the likelier one okay
uh yeah I you know I I think Dan the
Angels best opportunity to get Otani
back was by going out and making the
playoffs this year I don't think the
fact that he has a torn UCL
uh affects the calculus that he had
going into this winter which was I want
to go to a team that wins so if he goes
back to Anaheim I think that's probably
indicative of a market that just never
formed I just have a really hard time
believing that that Market's not going
to form but we we also have to
understand these teams that were valuing
Otani at such a high rate we're doing so
because of the uniqueness of what he
does because he essentially is two
players in one because you have a freed
up roster spot just by Dent of him being
who he is so when you look at the the
success or rather lack thereof Dan of
guys who have had two Tommy John
surgeries within a five-year span
um it's not a lot of guys who have come
back and been affected Jameson tion you
know got a 68 million dollar contract
from the Cubs this winter that's the
best that a two-time and five-year TJ
guy has done we've seen other guys like
Daniel Johnson uh you know Drew
Rasmussen who ended up needing a third
there's a kid with the Royals now Cole
Reagan's who looks really good but
there's not a long history of guys with
near concurrent Tommy John surgeries
going back out there and being really
good pitchers why don't we name the
surgery after the doctor who performed
the surgery not the first patient and
therefore Tommy John's surgery
oh yeah it was Frank Jobe surgery that
much better well he should get the
credit Tommy John just goes uh I don't
know what's wrong with my elbow all
right I'm Gonna Do by the way Tommy John
should be in the Baseball Hall of Fame
if you're looking at contributions to
the game
he was the first to have Tommy John
surgery and he had 288 wins I think in
his career shouldn't that warrant
Baseball Hall of Fame consideration
I'm a small haul kind of guy so I'm just
gonna say no okay okay all right I will
say this the the the the the the most
effective Tommy John surgery in the
procedures history was the original one
because not only did he come back
afterward and Pitch another decade and
win another 140 something games
uh it was seven years before the next
successful Thomas Johnson surgery Brent
Strom was the next one there were a
bunch of failures in there so this was
this almost looked like a unicorn
proceed I could spend a long time okay
one more thing I want to ask you Stephen
Strasberg announced his retirement did
he live up to the hype did he live up to
the hype
God that's such an interesting way to
phrase the question because I think in
some regards he did live up to the hype
I think he lived up to the hype on June
8 2010 when in his first start he struck
out 14 Pittsburgh Pirates didn't walk
one and looked like he was going to be
the best pitcher in the world for the
next decade and he wasn't he was the guy
who ended up again having Tommy John's
surgery shutting down uh you know a
couple septembers later when the
Nationals could have had a World Series
run and being really solid but never the
absolute best except for the one moment
where he had to be which was 2019
postseason that to me was when Steven
Strasberg lived up to the hype when he
made six appearances when 6-0 had a sub
2 era struck out the world didn't walk
anyone and put himself in a position to
get a 245 million dollar contract that
winter and since then he has pitched
fewer innings in aggregate it that he
did that entire October one month
compared to four years I think Stephen
Strasberg uh is the archetypal story Dan
for a modern picture which is that no
matter how much talent you have throwing
a baseball every fifth day at the
velocity and with the spin that guys
have to do right now in order to succeed
is a dubious proposition and something
that can absolutely wreck you and all I
hope for Stephen Strasberg is that his
arm problems do not affect him the rest
of his life because some of the troubles
that he's had over the past few years
have been really sad to hear about he's
Jeff passen not afraid to give you the
middle finger thank you Jeff it's always
great to talk to you always great to
talk to you I hope you're feeling better
I appreciate that Dad I would do it
right now but I'd probably get fired so
we're going to pass it on that fair
enough that's uh Jeff Bassett always
good to talk to him thank you buddy Jeff
pass into the Mothership